there's a satellite in orbit right now
that is taking pictures of fixed places
in our galaxy we've found several
planets out there that are very much
earth-like in other words water could
exist these planets are thousands of
light-years away so well I've never seen
aliens I don't think they've ever
visited the earth is it possible for
life to exist elsewhere in the universe
absolutely there are so many things to
do up there and if you ever are bored
look out the window I call looking out
the window down at earth sort of like
sitting around a campfire looking at it
you just can't take your eyes off it
every time there's a new adventure you
look you try to make out parts of the
continents you see if you can detect
something that's actually man-made
versus naturally made looking at the
earth or thunderstorms in the at night
is just one of the most amazing things
you can do
study hard stay in school of math
science very important fundamentals you
know NASA for several years had a couple
different ways to become an astronaut
one you could become a military pilot
and become a test pilot but then when
the Space Shuttle came around we found
new and innovative ways to bring people
who had degrees in medicine degrees in
geology biology because there was a lot
of research that was now to be to be
done in these orbiting laboratories that
we've been building for the last 30
years so hard science degree is
absolutely essential it's great if
you're a pilot but it's more important
that you study as hard as you can in you
stay in school we compacted as much as
we can there is no trash compactor in
space we keep it inside plastic bags to
keep it as odor free as long as possible
and then we pack it in Russian
containers and these Russian containers
are about the size of a small trash can
we put all of our trash in a Russian
progress unmanned cargo vehicle when
it's full we detach it and we let it
burn up in the atmosphere so we don't
just throw it out in space we make sure
that we we bring our trash back down to
earth or at least we vaporize it in the
Earth's atmosphere
I absolutely love space food you may
have conjure up images of early on
astronauts eating paste out of that of a
toothpaste dispenser space food is not
like that anymore they go to great
lengths to keep morale up because you
know the food that you eat actually
improves your mood they do a great job
of giving a wide variety of diet
selections my personal favorite was a
seafood gumbo and crawfish etouffee
by far the hardest part of space travel
is preparing for it on earth I used to
tell my crews before we launched on a
space shuttle mission that that one year
of investment that you put into that
two-week mission is the hardest part and
getting ready to launch that's like your
birthday that's when it's time to open
the presents and go and execute the plan
that you plan meticulously for the last
year so the answer to the question is it
technically possible absolutely with
today's technology we can we can launch
a human venture to Mars now it'll be
very very expensive and we will have to
you know justify that that huge
expenditure likely by enlisting the
collaboration of the spacefaring nations
of the globe to do it jointly actually
nASA has created what they call design
reference missions that involve pre
positioning fuel pre positioning a
habitat pre positioning a communication
system and a return device in in Martian
orbit
Claire I think that is an absolutely
wonderful idea there is places on the
moon where we have water in the form of
ice embedded inside the lunar regolith
of course water is an essential building
block to sustaining human life and being
able to extract that water out of the
lunar regolith and use it to drink to to
disassociate into oxygen and hydrogen
oxygen to breathe and hydrogen to use
for fuel I cannot think of a next
natural step that mankind can take off
the planet other than to set up a
permanent colony on the moon
I feel as though we can't afford not to
do it as you had mentioned we're not
doing a wonderful job of taking care of
our planet here on earth I wonder if
perhaps you know we always expect the
best but you know sometimes bad things
happen and is it good to perhaps set out
and maybe make a place that somebody can
go in the event something bad happens on
our own so and that's not the only
reason to go but that is a reason to
consider sort of a preservation of the
species theory and I personally believe
it's a great insurance policy for the
human race my name is Christopher
Ferguson I'm a former NASA astronaut and
I've blown on three different shuttle
flights I now work for the Boeing
Company is the deputy program manager
for operations for the cst-100 Starliner
Commercial Crew program